comment gagner du temps et s'économiser
des allers retours inutiles pendant les
périodes d'irrigation ce jeune
agriculteur beauceron a inventé la
solution une caméra connecter avec
panneaux solaires installés sur un
enrouleur la caméra est dirigée vers le
canon d'irrigation que vous voyez au
loin ce qui permet de s'assurer que le
jet d'eau et bien continue et fonctionne
bien et par ailleurs elles le film le
bord de la couronne ce qui permet de
s'assurer à distance que la l'enrouleur
s'enroule bien grâce à cette
installation
l'utilisateur peut surveiller en temps
réel depuis n'importe où sur son
téléphone mobile l'aspersion son champ
le principe de fonctionnement c'est très
simple on a une carte sim data dans le
dans la caméra que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure nous qui permet d'interroger à
distance un flux vidéo et donc vous avez
en temps réel votre champ avec votre
enrouleur qui tourne pour diffuser cette
invention julien doussineau s'est
associé à deux autres agriculteurs pour
fonder une start up et depuis le début
de l'année il commercialise les ricains
je suis moi même agriculteur donc j'ai
testé moi-même cette application est
cette caméra intelligente ce qui me
permet aujourd'hui d'expliquer à mes
confrères tout l'intérêt qu'ils ont à
gagner du temps et de l'argent
juste pour vous donner un petit calcul
cet appareil aujourd'hui on l'amorti en
65 jours si on prend en considération
les économies de temps et de carburant
nécessaire pour aller voir ses enrouleur
en dehors des périodes d'irrigation la
caméra peut servir à la surveillance des
cours de ferme et de ses bâtiments
depuis janvier 40 here i came ont déjà
été commercialisés